you look so good we cut all this hair
off you look adorable
listen i'm gonna get right to it i'm so
glad that you're here
we all said i said on the show i don't
know what's happening but somebody need
to fix something
because this ain't cool people were
upset people were upset and i was not
expecting it so i mean it's very
wonderful to be here i'm really thankful
to the academy for asking me to present
and uh and everyone at snow white who
was able to just let me get on between
yeah so we saw the queen rita was here
we saw ariana you know the movie is up
stephen is up what would it mean to you
to have this moment for this film i mean
it just means that our stories are worth
telling and i think just the the success
review eyes of our film shows that our
stories are worth telling but
recognition from something like this is
something that is so huge and a lot of
people pay attention to regardless of
whether or not you say like oh awards do
they really matter like you know at the
end of the day this is the story of
representation and it matters real quick
i do want to say so what did they do
like did they just call you after people
saw what happened i'll be honest i don't
know and i don't want to know
i kind of just let let it all the chips
fell where they did because i was
really overwhelmed with the response to
it because it was a comment i made on my
own instagram post you don't really
expect that to make the news the next
day and it was just a statement of fact
but we're here we're happy we're really
thankful